person a lights a candle  its light spreads in all directions  forming a bubble that grows  person b only sees the candle light up  when he receives the light or in other  words when he enters the  bubble once he has seen the candle light  up b cannot get out of the bubble  because to do so he would have to exceed  the speed of light  the surface of a star emits bubbles of  light as time goes by  but if the star collapses in on itself  it can become so compact that its  gravity pulls the fabric of space at the  speed of light  at some point its surface emits a final  bubble which attempts to grow but space  contracts the other way such that it  remains static  once inside it's impossible to get out  it is a black hole  black holes are bubbles of light frozen  by gravity  [Music]